juillet 2022 je suis contre je suis
content pour vous et du contrôle
sanitaire secousse avec notre solution
n'est pas celle là c'est toi on y
reviendra mais ignorent de question de
permettre pour reprendre l'expression de
gérard larcher mais que j'avais aussi
utiliser de donner un blanc seing au
gouvernement jusqu'au 31 juillet après
les élections présidentielle et
législatives ça sera quoi la position du
groupe socialiste en fin de semaine
prochaine ça veut dire on va jouer en
février c'est la position d'une
roturière dorian où on voit deux contres
au delà du 15 novembre votre compte on
vote contre on a voté une autre d'argent
en juillet puisque on considère cette un
pis-aller que c'est une manière de
procrastiner de reporter la décision
pour le gouvernement
et que les chiffres aujourd'hui même
s'ils ne sont pas aussi terrible qu'il
ya quelques mois montre quand même qu'à
une reprise de l'épidémie et si demain
il ya un nouveau variant pendant l'hiver
qu'est-ce qu'on fait donc nous on est
bête et discipliné entre guillemets
peut-être diront certains mais on croit
la vaccination est têtu et têtu donc
puisque vous risquez de relancer cette
question de la vaccination obligatoire
bien sûr y aura il y aura des
amendements en ce sens on va aller
jusqu'au bout c'est nous sommes dans une
cohérence la cohérence c'est que la
liberté individuelle
par rapport à cette situation sanitaire
doit s'arrêter là où commence l'intérêt
général collectif sanitaires et nous
considérons qu'aujourd'hui sur les huit
millions de français à peu près qui ne
sont pas du tout vacciner même pas une
première vaccination eh bien ils font
porter un risque à l'ensemble de la
collectivité nationale et donc je
respecte leur position mais je leur
demande de comprendre qu'à un moment
donné
on ne peut pas mettre son intérêt
personnel au devant et vous savez les
gers idée par centaines des insultes des
injures des menaces même des menaces de
mort par rapport au texte que j'ai porté
comme premiers signataires sur le maxi
nation obligatoire et beaucoup
d'arguments et était vraiment sur un
égoïsme effrénée en disant mais vous
vacciner vous c'est vous qui allez nous
apporter l'immunité collective mais nous
on reste dans notre cocon pour une
partie pas pour tous mais c'est quand
même extrêmement dramatique
[Musique]